Nos dicen que: "Marc tiene una piscina inflable
en su patio trasero. La piscina es cilíndrica.
El área de su base es de 4 metros cuadrados
y tiene una altura de 60 centímetros. ¿Cuál
es el volumen de la piscina en metros cúbicos?"
Pausa el video e intenta encontrar la respuesta.
Bien, vamos a trabajar juntos, y primero
visualicemos la piscina inflable cilíndrica,
se va a ver algo así. Una piscina inflable es
una pequeña piscina donde puedes pasar un rato,
aunque no se puede nadar demasiado en ella, y
se va a ver algo así. Ya sé que el dibujo no
es perfecto porque está hecho a mano, la estoy
dibujando transparente para que podamos ver la
base. Entonces, la piscina inflable se va a ver
algo así, y nos dicen que el área de la base es de
4 metros cuadrados, es decir, esta área de aquí,
esta es la base, y es de 4 m², y tiene una altura
de 60 cm, nos dicen, entonces esta altura es de 60
cm. Y, bueno, nuestra primera reacción podría ser:
bien el volumen de un cilindro se obtiene al
multiplicar el área de su base por su altura (b •
h). En este caso por qué no multiplicamos 4 • 60 y
así obtenemos un volumen de 240. Y como lo quieren
en metros cúbicos, escribiremos 240 m³, y ya está.
¿Es cierto esto?, ¿lo hicimos de manera correcta?
Bueno, quizá algunos de ustedes se dieron cuenta
que al multiplicar no multiplicamos 4 m² • 60 m
para obtener 240 m³, multiplicamos 4 m² • 60 cm, y
si multiplicas estas dos unidades, tus unidades no
serán los metros cúbicos, terminaríamos con
metros cuadrados centímetros como unidades,
que no es lo que nos piden, de hecho ese es un
conjunto de unidades muy extrañas. Entonces,
para obtener como respuesta metros cúbicos
necesitamos expresar 60 cm en términos de
metros cúbicos. Bueno, ¿cuántos metros son 60 cm?
Cien centímetros hacen 1 metro, entonces podemos
escribirlo de esta forma: si 100 cm = 1 m, u
otra forma de pensarlo es que 1 cm = 1/100 m,
1/100, entonces 60 cm = 60/100 m. Ahora, podemos
aplicar esto para trabajar con metros de manera
consistente. Esto no es correcto. Y entonces
nos queda que el volumen será igual a la base en
metros cuadrados -voy a escribir las unidades para
asegurarnos de que estamos haciendo lo correcto-
por la altura, es decir, por 60 / 100 metros o 60
centésimos de metro. Y ahora todo funciona: 40 •
60 / 100 será 240 / 100, y luego metros cuadrados
por metro es metros cúbicos, que es exactamente
lo que nos piden. Y por supuesto podemos
escribir esto como 2.4 m³. Y hemos acabado.